glen asks can you elaborate on what the
middle is and why it sucks glad this is
a great question you know to me the
middle is the commodity work and
thinking that everybody else does
meaning it's what the markets doing
right now like it's it's one startups
officially we're gonna do something in
the photo app space
you mean like everybody's been doing for
the last five years it's it's commodity
work you know i think that if you're not
trying to break things you're not doing
a good job or back to clouds and dirt
non-mental if you're not doing like you
know so funny i've sat through four
pitches today and i've liked two and one
is because the two guys are just doing
the work they're like in the weeds
they're not doing the big holistic
branding thinking game-changing stuff
they're just executing but at a raw
level I just find that there's not that
many hardcore practitioners and there's
even less big where's the world going
you know one of those friends at the
highest level or am i doing the kind of
things at the highest level and so I
don't really know how to explain the
work but you're surrounded I'm sorry I
don't really know how to explain the
middle but you're surrounded by it 99.9
percent of your life oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe